- [Joe] I think, like everybody,
I'm interested in stories
about ghosts or extraterrestrials.
Some people would say,
"Well don't explain that,
"don't explain that.
"I wanna believe that."
People call me a debunker.
They say I'm trying to disprove;
I'm raining on their parade,
and you know what?
I don't apologize at all for
trying to find the truth.
- [News Reporter] And Joe
Nickell from the Committee
for Skeptical Inquiry.
- [Announcer] We've invited
renowned skeptic, Joe Nickell,
to meet Cora Lorenzo.
- This medieval
superstition has got to go.
And this is really just, just silly.
I'm Joe Nickell, and I'm a
paranormal investigator.
I investigate everything
from monsters, ghosts,
aliens, psychics, for
a science organization
and the magazine, Skeptical Inquirer.
I knew at the age of eight
that I was a detective,
but I eventually became a stage magician.
Oh my goodness!
My models were Harry
Houdini and other magicians
who used their magic
talents to expose trickery.
And meanwhile, like
everybody, I was curious
about haunted houses and flying saucers,
and I decided I wanted to
do something like that.
I've written about 40 books,
primarily on mysteries.
A lot of cases were miracle claims
or some kind of religious claims.
Spontaneous human combustion,
lake monster mysteries,
crop circles, UFO sightings, chupacabras,
ghosts, Bigfoot.
(paper shuffling)
What I'm trying to do
is actually investigate,
looking for facts and clues.
As you begin to put together a case file,
you fill the file folder
with what data you have,
and then trying to find
actually corroborative evidence,
so that I can try to
explain what's happening,
explain a UFO sighting.
My explanations are often quite mundane.
People report seeing these long-necked,
multi-humped lake monsters.
There are many things that
can create the illusion
of a lake monster, including
two, or three, or four otters
swimming in line,
which create the effect
of one large creature.
Bigfoot is a tall,
hairy, bipedal creature.
There is a creature that
looks very much like Bigfoot.
That is a black bear or a brown bear,
standing, sniffing the
air and walking about.
People driving by an old
mansion in the little community
of Burt, New York sometimes
reported seeing a ghostly figure
dressed in white.
As it turns out, they'd had
a mannequin dressed in white
in the window and that was responsible
for many of those sightings.
I think part of me would
like for there to be ghosts,
and for there to be extraterrestrials,
but I've done this a long
time and I'm pretty sure
that ghosts don't exist.
Even the skeptics who
like what I do will often,
their first reaction is
hmm, that's pretty obvious.
Everything is obvious
after it's been explained.
(fun chiming music)